time now for today's speed round brought
to you by verizon 5g
built right let's get to it peter king
super bowl 55 who can help their legacy
the most with a big performance in super
bowl 55
in my opinion bruce aryans
i think aryans has
ever since he was unceremoniously
retired by the pittsburgh steelers in
2011.
um he's won coach of the year twice
and he's got the tampa bay buccaneers he
helped recruit tom brady whatever that
came down to
and now he's in the super bowl to me
he's not just
a great offensive coach
if the tampa bay buccaneers win this
game he helps his legacy significantly
uh if he wins this game if the bucks win
this game
i think that's a great point and that
makes me even more convinced that he's
going to pull out all the stops and i'm
not talking about ridiculous trick plays
i'm just talking about a willingness to
be
hyper aggressive maybe no punts all game
maybe onside kicks every time they go to
kick off not that they would do that
because you can't really recover on
sidekicks anymore all that often but
just a level of aggressiveness
more than what we're used to seeing from
a guy who's already got that no risk it
no biscuit mentality i obviously think
that patrick mahomes can help his legacy
the most to get two super bowl wins in
three years as a starter and to keep tom
brady from getting to seven that's the
key it's either gonna be six and two or
seven and one
so he's gonna have
six
to catch brady or four to catch brady
not that he's ever guaranteed to catch
brady but it's a hell of a lot easier
peter if you come out of this game only
behind by four
but mike here's here's the one thing i
would add to this
how amazing would it be
in terms of nfl history okay if patrick
mahomes wins wins his second super bowl
by the age of 25
and if you combine the number of years
that aaron rodgers and drew brees has
played i think it's 900 okay but if you
combine the number of years they've only
won two and so to to have won two
by the time you're 25 years old when
rogers and brees together have won two
is really would really be an amazing
feat
all right let's put the pedal to the
metal and get through the rest of these
who be the baddest defensive dude on the
field in super bowl 55
i'll take frank clark when the chiefs
decided to basically invest 40 million
dollars a year
in you know their two big guys in the
middle of the field or you know on the
defensive line frank clark chris jones
to me
i think what that said is that these are
our long-term
pests on the defensive line and in this
particular game i think frank clark he
comes off a two-sack game against
buffalo and i think he is really hitting
his stride playing great down the
stretch i'll take frank clark
i'll take devon white i've been so
impressed with his play in the
postseason he's he's in your face
without crossing the line he's he's
chippy but not too chippy he sets the
tone for that defense and and he's the
guy who gives them that lift when they
need it and he's all over the place so i
got devon white underrated storyline
peter that deserves more attention
steve spagnolo
trying to design something and you
remember mike he once designed an
incredible defensive game plan to
totally absolutely frustrate
tom brady in a shocking new york giants
victory and so i just keep thinking to
myself if i'm brady
i'm going to bed at night and i'm
thinking back
at the most nightmarish day i've ever
had on a big stage and i'm saying hmm
what does steve spagnolo have in store
for me this time
and that was mine so let me pivot
quickly to another one there's this
theory that's making the rounds and it's
not from anyone who's in the business
but fans are saying hmm maybe andy reid
will retire after winning two in a row
and eric b enemy just takes over the
chiefs andy reid's not going anywhere
folks andy r first of all it gives him a
chance to be the only guy to ever win
three in a row and second of all the
house is built all you got to do is sit
on the couch
right peter i mean you got patrick
mahomes i'd never retire i'm staying in
this job as long as patrick holmes is
here because i may end up with six or
seven rings of my own i could rival bill
belichick by the time it's all said and
done
i think that's a great point but mike
the one thing i i would i would say
about that is that
each game
stands on its own it's why when i was
talking to brady sunday night he just he
he
he really finds it hard to put into
words about the singular importance of
or significance of making ten super
bowls he's just kind of in the moment
and that's why i think you've got to
take each one of these on their own
this is the speed round brought to you
by verizon 5g built right we're going
into hyper speed round to get through
these last two more important that he
returned for the super bowl sammy
watkins for the chiefs or antonio brown
for the buccaneers
i would have said antonio brown until
two games ago when tyler johnson now has
become a huge factor for the tampa bay
buccaneers so i will take watkins
because
you never know
if a guy like machole hardman you know
might make a couple of mistakes and then
make sami watkins all the more important
as the chief alternative to tyreek hill
in the speed game
and remember
sammy watkins had that huge play last
year when he ran by richard sherman
inspired by davonte adams running by
richard sherman in the nfc championship
does gronk have one big moment in him
i think he's got five big moments in him
i think you're gonna see rob gronkowski
emerge uh and play like this game is
gonna be his last it's not gonna be his
last but i think he's gonna play like a
classic rob gronkowski leave it all out
there
they had that beautiful play design
where scotty miller came in motion from
left
to right spun around went back everyone
thought it was going that way it was a
quick little screen to gronk and he
rumbled for 29 yards or thereabouts i
want to see one of those big gronk
catches down the seam he's you know he's
a little slower than he used to be so
tom's got to take some of the mustard
off of it but uh here's hoping to see
gronk he had the he had the play in
super bowl 53 that really was the back
breaker for the rams we'll see if he can
do it again all right that was the
verizon speed round we're going to take
a break when we return we will get into
our draft for this friday edition of pft
live off season quarterback movement
that we'd love to see we'll be right
back
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon 5g built right
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports